a few days ago I built a next-gen
Discord killer with pocket base and
svelt it was an amazing experience for
about three minutes but then you guys
completely destroyed it by spamming it
with the most deranged comments I've
ever seen on the internet I initially
started with a five dollar Linux server
its usage quickly shot up to 100 so I
resized it to four cores that wasn't
nearly enough juice either and all four
cores quickly became overwhelmed and
this is why we can't have nice things on
this channel the primary person to blame
for all this is me the developer I built
it with bad security practices by Design
just to see what would happen fun to do
bad things luckily I live in America so
I can't go to jail for the horrible
things you guys said unlike other
countries but nobody wants to use an app
that can be spammed by an unlimited
amount of hate speech and profanity this
is a major problem when building any
kind of app with user generated data in
today's video we'll break down all the
problems my app had and talk about tools
and techniques you can use to mitigate
these issues in your own projects the
first problem is that people were using
profanity even though I told them not to
they didn't listen their language is
offensive I thought this might have
happen so I implemented a pooping system
where if a comment gets pooped on five
times it gets removed from the UI I've
seen this feature on other platforms
like Odyssey where you can slime a
comment to death and I think it's a good
idea but it doesn't really work for a
chat where the messages are moving at
100 miles an hour it can also be
hijacked by the bad guys to poop down
all the comments that are actually good
so the next thing I did which is really
easy to implement is just a bad word
filter directly in the front end code
that means the app can't display words
like [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] balls and so on you
can also do filtering like this on the
back end before that data ever goes to
your database but it's impossible to
catch everything with regular
Expressions the trolls will find ways to
say bad words with alternative
characters that bypass your filters in
modern times though artificial
intelligence is starting to take over
this job in Google developed perspective
API which can detect if something is an
insult or some variation of profanity
and they use tools like this at scale to
keep the worst of the worst comments off
of YouTube bad words are one problem but
an even bigger problem is when one
person creates a script that
automatically signs up new users and
they all start spamming the same
horrible messages hundreds of times per
second in my chat app all you need is a
username and password to sign up but
that's not nearly enough friction for
any real world application at the very
least you should require an email and
have that user verify the email before
they start posting messages pocketbase
has a built-in email system that can
handle this step for you then you can
check the verified status and security
rules for messages that's a step in the
right direction but it's still not
perfect it's not hard to verify a burner
email that's why nowadays you see almost
all large-scale applications requiring
multi-factor authentication where a user
also needs to verify a phone number with
a text message or via an authenticator
app to do anything important this can
also be faked but it's way more
difficult still though someone could
register with a burner phone and once
again spam the chat with horrible
messages another step you can take is to
verify that the person on the front end
is an actual human by implementing a
captcha that in theory can only be
solved by a real human Google's
recaptcha is the most popular option but
cloudflare also now has a free
alternative called Turn Style file and
either option can help validate that
requests are actually coming from a
human inside your app if you're a
Firebase user this is actually built
into the platform with a tool called app
check which is saved my ass multiple
times that can help with Bots but it's
not going to stop some deranged lunatic
or someone from the FBI social media
team from posting awful messages as a
legitimate human being another step
you'll want to take is to implement rate
limiting on the back end this prevents
one single user from submitting too many
requests within a given time period a
human can only do so much and if you see
an account breaking past that threshold
then you just shut it off for a while
now the final thing I want to talk about
is problem scaling the infrastructure
normally on this channel we use
serverless tools that can scale
infinitely in the cloud without any
regard for your wallet if this video was
unique because we hosted the entirety of
the back end that includes the rest API
the admin dashboard and the database
itself on a five dollar Linux server in
just one day over 300 000 messages were
created and pocketbase also recorded
millions of logging records to go along
with all the requests to the API the
pocket-based Creator left you really
nice comment on that video explaining
some improvements we could make like
increasing the open file limit to get
the real-time connections to scale
better also keep in mind that pocketbase
is a very early stage project that
hasn't even hit 1.0 yet overall I'm
extremely impressed at how it scaled
with its limited resources and thousands
of real-time connections the front end
app got really laggy just due to the
fire hose of messages and the admin app
also froze up a couple of times when I
try to delete some of the worst users
and messages but the admin dashboard
never crashed completely and I could
always access the data there most
importantly I could always update the
rules to globally disable new message
creation I did that for about an hour so
I could go have a nice healthy and
relaxing lunch at Arby's I left a
message from the official fireship
account explaining that the chat had
been disabled due to extreme toxicity as
I sat down and began to enjoy my roast
beef sandwich and curly fries I went in
to double check the chat and found that
Toshi Michi 1724 found an exploit to
overwrite my message in addition to any
other user in the chat this is my fault
for not defining robust security rules
but all I could do was sit there and cry
while eating my strawberries and cream
fried pie now available for a limited
time at participating restaurants now
even though you guys were able to
overwhelm and totally wreck the app I
don't feel ashamed or humiliated for
this great dishonor I have brought upon
the art of programming ultimately
moderating and controlling spam on a
massive chat app is a nearly impossible
task even Discord struggles with it to
this day we've had to jump through all
kinds of Hoops to prevent raids and spam
on our Discord server if you're crazy
enough to build your own massive public
chat room all I can say is good luck and
may God be with you thanks for watching
and I will see you in the next one